Oh,
hey fella,
what do you got there?
What does that legal marijuana and your hands do you want a closer look?
You activist you,
I'm such a radical man.
The streets are not safe when I'm out on the loose radical seem like a regular
guy.
Regular guy with the irregular amount of stress.
The walrus right there,
dude.
You don't mind mind putting it there?
No,
no,
not at happy to come back and see it.
No,
it stays on the desk.
Yeah.
That thinks this means as much to us as anybody except for you.
Well,
it's nice to see it.
This is my,
uh,
this is my happy place.
This is my safe place.
I got to travel across the country to be safe.
But uh,
it's,
it's certainly a pleasure to be here.
Getting a joy.
Always have to.
Thank you.
All right.
Listen brother,
I think you too.
I was texting Whitney today.
I said,
you're a hero.
You're a legitimate hero for people.
Don't know what this is all about.
I'll give everybody in the back story.
Um,
Phil used to work at marine land.
He was an orchid trainer and he also trained a walrus named smooshy and smooshy
is still allegedly in captivity at marine land.
All those,
no photographic evidence,
but you're pretty sure she's still there.
I was told that she is still there and she's in good shape.
And I'm hanging onto that.
Since you came on the podcast the first time,
which was how many years ago?
No,
so six years ago,
I think.
2013.
So He's been living this lawsuit life for six years,
trapped in a lawsuit with a gigantic corporation with incredible amounts of
money that's been trying to crush them.
And um,
they've made up stuff.
Well,
tell me what's,
what's happened you give,
give me your,
your perspective on how it all went down.
Back in 2012,
I made,
I was forced to make a very difficult decision.
I elected to speak out against the conditions of which,
uh,
marine lands animals were living in.
Um,
I did so knowing the risks,
knowing that marine land was allotted Tejas company,
but I did so on account of the fact that the animals were suffering incredibly
okay.
Uh,
before quitting,
I had an agreement with marine land that,
look,
I'm leaving.
This is long before I'd spoke up,
I'd spoken out,
I'm leaving.
But you know,
we have to establish that I can maintain this relationship with the walrus
because I imprinted on her.
It's important to stress that,
that she thinks I'm her mom.
She was a baby,
she was a baby when she came in,
so she was wild caught and you can imagine,
probably witnessed her mother gets slaughtered.
That's the,
uh,
that's the method of collecting babies,
um,
by the,
by the captors in Russia.
And,
uh,
so she comes in traumatic at the age of,
we estimate about 18 months of age,
which is pretty old.
In fact,
uh,
for,
in our experience I'm marine lines experience of,
of acquiring these wild caught baby walruses.
Um,
and through a sort of traumatic experience with her that I was there with her.
This anomalous thing happened where her brain circuitry
opened up and much like in the wild,
where in the case of hurt animals,
the babies,
uh,
become familiar with the mother's sound scent.
Look everything,
all the senses are acute there.
They're aware of who they have,
where they are,
so that they can find each other amidst these thousands of animals.
Well,
this happened to her,
so the brain circuitry opens.
Suddenly I'm imprinted on her.
I wasn't prepared to leave marine land unless it was of the understanding that I
can continue to help her because historically my relationship with her,
uh,
you know,
had everything to do with her health and wellbeing.
I quit with the understanding with marine land.
This was to be the case.
I'd been gone for a month.
I come back on announced they don't want to let me in.
They're hiding something.
I get in,
I see her.
She's in terrible shape.
I snap a few photos.
I leave now amidst this terrible shape.
What do you mean?
She was amazing?
She was bone dry.
She hadn't eaten in my,
having been gone a month was the longest she and I've ever actually been
physically apart.
I'd been trying to wean my presence off of her so that other trainers could be
able to maintain a healthy,
you know,
healthy diet for healthy lifestyles.
She was amazing because she wasn't eating because there's trust.
I wasn't there for that month,
I can't say,
but she was certainly not eating.
She was super skinny.
Um,
they had her,
of course on a bunch of drugs which include psychotics,
Valium,
antidepressants.
Um,
I,
when I saw her,
my jaw hit the floor.
It's important to note that during this,
um,
some newspapers had been calling.
They wanted to know why I quit.
If we back up a little bit,
it should be noted that in 2007,
my relationship with Smu,
she sort of took off in the early sort of Internet viral days and whatnot.
Um,
we made front page of like CNN and uh,
Jimmy Kimmel did a piece and uh,
so there was sort of that backstory of the,
I guess you would call it a fluff celebrity type thing,
but nonetheless,
might,
having left started,
people started asking questions.
I started fielding calls from this newspaper who was looking,
it was keen on doing an investigation of marine land.
So I wasn't going to participate.
I had no interest.
Again,
stressing the marine lines,
La Tejas history.
And also look,
I've got this relationship with a walrus that I sort of have to maintain.
I have to re,
I have to keep this relationship with marine land healthy enough.
So once I'd realized they weren't holding on to that end of the bargain,
you know,
the panic sets in,
I'm a first time mom,
it should be stressed.
Uh,
so I,
I basically call the newspapers and I said,
you put my face,
my name on it doesn't matter.
You just print it.
Let's go,
let's,
let's get the story out.
Story gets out.
Well,
marine le as expected starts their lawsuits.
It's like a,
it's almost like a scorched earth.
They take a scorched earth,
uh,
sort of a method.
And this was when the original owner was alive.
Yes,
yes.
No longer alive.
He died
during this last year in,
uh,
in June.
In fact,
so,
uh,
years into this litigation.
So I'm okay.
They sued me.
They sued me for 1,000,005.
They sued my girlfriend.
They sued other activists.
They sued newspapers.
They,
they're suing everybody.
The mistake they made is in all of their absurd allegations that they've yet six
and a half years into into litigation yet to prove any of it.
They cannot.
It's never going to happen.
It doesn't exist.
It's a fictitious lawsuit.
It's full of lies and bullshit.
Bottom line.
The mistake they made is they sued me for plotting to steal smooshy.
That's where the headlines take off and Oh,
they also called me the Kanye west of animal training.
Yeah,
I remember we went,
that's how I got your attention on the Internet and this is what I know.
That's not how you got my attention.
I still tweet.
I say,
yeah,
but the Kanye west part didn't get my,
well,
no.
You said they called you.
The tweet was,
I said,
Joe,
you just say when I'll book a flight to come to la.
I sent you the link to the,
to the story.
The headline was Kanye west of animal training being sued for plotting to steal
of Waller's.
You wrote,
they called you though what and then you slid into the DMZ and said,
dude,
if you're ever in La,
I said,
you just say when?
Well,
I started reading
the story when I started.
I have,
you know,
I wrote a um,
a piece of long time ago on my blog and I'm um,
I talked about it in one of my comedy specials that I had a crazy experience
with dolphins once,
um,
when I was really,
really high and I had this,
um,
I mean it sounds silly to even talk about,
but I almost feel like I kind of understood that they are like us,
but they just don't alter their environment.
What I realized like when they were playing with us,
when they were jumping by the boat and they were looking at you,
they're looking at you while they were jumping around with the boat and I was
like,
they're playing and they're looking at you like a person would like a water
person interacting.
There's almost a language at this point.
There's some level of bridged gap in the communication.
When you get to see that they're expressing themselves in interest in you and
whatnot and scoping you.
And when you get really close and establish a relationship with these animals,
that's when things start getting real squirrely because you start to find that
happy medium language.
All of a sudden you are starting to sort of speak,
so to say.
Yeah,
well I started getting really weird,
um,
feelings about seaworld and an animal captivity like this.
Why do we need that in this day and age?
Like this isn't the dark ages.
We shouldn't be putting whales and orcas and dolphins putting them in these
tanks,
these fucking water swimming pools.
They're fucking swimming pools.
And you have these things that are probably as smart as us and some different
way,
like we're so prejudiced in that we only think of intelligence as something that
can manipulate its environment.
That's our problem.
Like
we like,
look at them.
They're a bitch ass world.
They don't have any houses.
They can't write a letter.
They,
they're fucking stupid man.
Stop it.
They're stupid.
But dolphins apparently have a cerebral cortex.
It's something around 40% larger than a human beings.
They have super complex languages.
Their emotional intelligence is the mystery and it appears that it's far beyond
anything.
We ourselves can understand that same as orcas.
They've got that,
uh,
they've got another part of the brain in the front,
which is its function in that the front of the cerebral Cortex,
that function is to,
um,
as for communication and for,
and for,
it enhances their emotional capacity to a point where we don't really know the
depth of which they are,
the power of their emotion.
But we know that they stay with their families for their lifetimes.
The males born,
uh,
from,
from the mothers will,
will rarely leave the mother's side.
Quite literally the distance of an Orca itself.
They only time that mail will go on is when it's matured and it will go to
procreate and then back to the mother.
And it will live its entire life as such.
And the sad fact about that is in my experience,
uh,
working with male Orkos caught from the,
one of which caught from the wild,
a big bull Orca is,
he's a mama's boy.
You can see something was missing.
He was traumatized from something.
And of course,
even myself as a regarded whale expert in the capacity of working at a fricking
place like marine land,
even,
I would have never known this information when I started this.
This is not information that was available to us back in.
I started in 2000.
It makes sense now.
This animal's traumatized from birth.
His will to live is just gone.
It's at and the male,
it appears to me and in my experience,
the male sex of,
uh,
well I've worked with seals,
I've worked with sea lions,
I've worked with a wall versus a Dolphin's,
Belugas and orcas.
All of them die younger.
The males die younger and I think,
well definitely in the orchids and the dolphins cases is they just don't have
that will to live without that strong maternal figure in their life.
This is what I tried to explain to people that don't see it and they think that
the,
the dolphins get treated well or the orchids get treated well.
This is what,
imagine if someone stole your son and put him in an air box at the bottom of the
ocean and dolphins and whales and fish just came by and stared at them.
Imagine.
And he lives his life like that with no contact other than with his,
his dolphin handlers or whoever's taking care of him.
And he just lives in this box,
missing his family,
missing his loved ones,
missing his life,
confused,
lost,
and with,
with a language that is,
especially with orcas and dolphins,
they have a language.
It's so complex.
We haven't been able to really decipher it.
We don't understand how it works.
You know,
John Lilly spent,
they spent I
think,
decades working on trying to get dolphins to speak human noises.
He had a bunch of studies that he did and um,
he even had an I sore.
It's a crazy story.
I'm sure you've heard of the woman who lived with the Dolphin.
She,
she'd try to establish a relationship with the dolphin where she,
they made an apartment that was half under water,
but the dolphin always wanted to fuck,
so she just jerked the dolphin off and when she jerked the dolphin off,
that was the only thing that calmed him down and then she could do her work.
So for her it was just like a technicality.
I just got a jerk.
This dolphin off,
it's a in the animal,
they wants to be rubbed all the moral stuff that's attached to that as all in my
own head.
She's like,
I'm just going to be a scientist.
And they were like,
get that fuck.
What?
Think they were also injecting ketamine into the dolphins or something as well.
Do not know if they were doing that in two dolphins,
but I do know that they did some experiments with Lsd and that John Lilly,
who was one of my personal heroes,
he's the creator of the flotation tank.
This is all John Lilly's stuff.
He was a pioneer in interspecies communication.
He would take acid and think that he was communicating with dolphins.
Did you know you're on the cover of one of his books?
What?
Yes,
we are talking about your face.
It,
I mean it's,
it's a spitting image on,
in one of his books to Lily's books.
Do this.
Happy to look this up.
Maybe the superior single time travel are shit.
They are you man.
I'm sorry I was,
that's fucking tired man.
That's fucking weird.
Yeah.
Wow.
So that's a pro.
I can't read that.
What does it say something?
The human bio computer bio.
Yeah.
I didn't read that one.
I read the deep self though.
The diff self's really interesting.
Um,
and the deep self.
I think the deep self is the one that also has,
um,
diagrams on how to build a tank.
He was trying to get people to build tanks.
He was like,
listen man,
I found some shit out.
You got to try this.
The last time I was here,
uh,
not the last time.
Two Times ago.
You actually,
uh,
sent me to crash.
Yeah.
Man.
Crash and have to crash the float lab.
Yeah.
And He,
uh,
you know,
I thought I'd be in there for an hour.
It turns out I was in there for a couple and when I came and I'm like,
dude,
I was waiting for the knock.
He's just like,
oh no man,
it's just letting you stay in there.
I'm like,
Oh shit,
I'm looking at the time crashes.
A lick of legit hippie.
The Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
he's great.
He's great.
He's the mad scientist behind float lab.
Yeah.
That's why those things are so well engineered.
When I met him I was like,
what?
I was like,
cause I tanks before that,
when I,
I,
I first got a tank in like 2002,
somewhere around there,
2000,
two,
2003.
And um,
it was uh,
it was great,
but it was like,
it would break,
things would go wrong.
It flooded my basement.
It was like there was disasters.
It wasn't.
And then,
um,
my friend who was a,
a tank technician,
there's actually tank technicians.
He said,
listen,
you got to go check out this guy in Venice.
So some mad scientists down there in Venice was just making these over
engineered
float tanks.
And he goes,
they look like walk him meat lockers.
Right.
I was like,
why is she showed Rod,
you had like a pod installed it.
It was a very good tank.
It's just,
uh,
it just,
it wasn't as well constructed.
Also wasn't nearly as expensive.
It's just he went the distance,
he went the distance and he still keeps,
keeps coming over here.
I've got to change things.
I got it.
We're upgrading,
we're doing that.
It's like he's always gone to him and trying to enhance the experience for
everyone.
I mean,
yeah,
he's always trying to make it better.
He's the front of the line.
And when I first started working with him,
like when I first started having him on the podcast and I hired him to build me
a tank and all that channels,
like there was no tanks.
There was,
it was real rare that you'd find tank centers now.
They're fucking everywhere,
man.
Everywhere.
I'll say this,
the experience I had in his tank versus the one that I,
there's a local place,
uh,
from where,
where I'm from,
uh,
was hands down at different experience because he really isolates you there.
Whereas these,
this was like a pod that they bought and installed in her room.
I mean it was great.
Please is super insulated so there's no fucking noise getting in that thing.
And he gave me the tour of the whole backstage to her.
I was all back to checking shit out.
I was like,
wow,
he's got a serious complex there.
It's hard to appreciate.
But when he first started making tanks like that,
which again,
I think I bought one of his tanks in 2005,
I think somewhere around then,
dude,
there was no one making anything like that.
He was,
he's making these super high end,
crazy fucking double wall insulated tanks and you get in there,
it's just,
yeah,
Justin,
nothing and you just want to get swollen.
Oh,
you just get taken into the eye.
This,
it's a good place to think about the subject that we're talking about today.
We got to stop doing that with dolphins and orchids.
It's going to be thought of the same way we think about slavery today.
It's her that it's horrific.
We can't understand that.
We can't believe that compassionate human beings would be willing to isolate the
members of a super social,
highly intelligent animal species and just put them in swimming pools.
It's fucking barbaric.
It's crazy.
It's torture.
It's,
it's what's sad here is,
you know,
we're a years removed from the documentary blackfish and you know,
that was really impactful.
I mean,
arguably a responsible for the paradigm shift that we're,
that we're experiencing here in North America and other places of course.
Um,
but maybe it's time for people to revisit it.
I know seaworld,
uh,
their stock and their value is sort of going up now.
Granted,
they,
you know,
they changed their numbers.
They skew it,
they have free beer day,
they pump the numbers up,
you know,
they have all these different promotions,
whatever.
I mean,
everything that comes out of these,
these facilities,
these assume it to be all bullshit by the way,
that it's all bullshit,
but not enough people questioned them on it.
But as we speak,
while we're a mid sort of a paradigm shift here and,
uh,
I mean I can speak to it because I mean,
I'm very happy to say that we have very effectively decimated marine land and
we'll talk more about that.
But,
uh,
over in China,
this is now a burgeoning
a business.
And I,
and I did,
we discuss this a year and a half ago and it's,
it's tenfold now.
It's happening very quickly.
And I'm sure you're familiar with the whale jail situation in Russia.
Have you seen that?
No,
I am not.
They've got a enclosed in this bay.
They've got over a hundred,
a wild caught belugas and orcas.
So there's about 10 orchids,
if I'm not mistaken.
And uh,
some activists flew a drone over it.
This got worldwide attention,
a lot of outcry,
a lot of anger,
of course.
Um,
so what happened was Jim,
he showed it to us right now for the folks that are listening and we're looking
down at the what looks like swimming pools with,
uh,
I guess those are Belugas,
those have all been sold.
Those are essentially sold and ready to go to China.
Uh,
but on account of the fact that the activists got this and created a real
worldwide stink,
um,
all the negative press that came of it,
they've now resolved that they want to try to,
well,
they've,
they've hard considered,
uh,
releases.
Um,
the governor in the area signed a intent to release agreement with the world,
sang with the whale sanctuary project,
uh,
who sent a team to assess the animal's health and whatnot.
And this was all of like three weeks ago.
It's not a long time ago.
And they assessed that all these animals should be released.
It's a couple of issues.
There's a couple of things that,
that are becoming conflicting.
A,
it's going to require a lot of costs if it's done responsibly be,
it appears.
Okay.
So what's happened is,
as we know,
Russia's not exactly a democratic environment.
Only one person makes the decisions on account of what becomes of these whales.
Whereas there was some PR stunts to say,
Hey,
we're going to,
we want to release them.
We want to do this to sort of mitigate the global outrage.
The captors have propagandize this entire effort to,
to free these whales as a means for the west to undermine the Russia's Russia's
economy.
So the whale trade economy,
here's where marine land comes into play in a,
in a theory at this point,
but it has these very intense implications.
What we know about what marine lend is doing currently in their transition from
brilliantly successful business to virtually decimated.
Thank you.
Um,
is there shipping their whales out?
We know too,
um,
are going out.
If it's not this week,
it'll be very soon.
I'll be shocked if they're not out.
I'm in La,
so I can't say that it's happening right now.
I think it may very well be happening this week.
They're going to Spain.
We know that five other permits have been,
uh,
requested to send these animals now to the states.
So it was that they're liquidating their,
the intent.
Yeah,
they're,
they're going through liquidating.
But the issue is
if in fact Russia kept catches wind,
that marine land is sent,
sending their whales,
let's use the worst case scenario to China.
It validates the Russian captors propaganda and concerns.
Suddenly what we're concerned is going to happen is those animals,
suddenly Putin says,
forget it.
Sell them,
ship them out.
That's,
that's a scenario.
But why would he do that?
Because again,
the,
the captains of propaganda is that the west wants to cripple the Russia's
economy there.
They're wild whale sale economy.
So if it's marine land is selling whales to China from Canada,
then suddenly the captains have a point,
they'll say to Putin,
look there,
they're selling whales.
Why is it such an outrage that Russia's doing it when marine lands doing it?
So there's that concern.
The other one,
and this just came up within the last 20 hours,
is it appears rather than go the most responsible route,
which we know is going to be a costly endeavor,
but you know,
we're game and we're ready is a,
they're now considering just dropping the nets and saying see you later.
And letting all the animals go,
here's what we suspect they're going to let the orcas go because they were
captured illegally.
Uh,
there's some gray area as to whether the Beluga whales I've been captured
illegally or not.
So I think it'll probably start with the archis rather than move them to where
they were at the same time of year,
uh,
when they were captured so that they can be next to their po,
their trends,
uh,
transient pods or their,
their,
um,
their pods.
They just want to drop this,
this net and say,
see you later.
Well,
that's as irresponsible as it can get,
but that's crazy.
It's like making someone a slave for how many years are the years somewhere on
the planet.
But imagine there,
hope you can imagine it would be,
oh,
see it didn't work.
Oh,
Jesus.
There's a lot of,
there's a,
this is a big issue.
Uh,
we're on it.
There's a,
there's a great team of activists over there.
Would it be accurate to say that maybe what these groups are doing right now is
recognizing that there's probably going to be some radical changes in the way
these things are permitted?
What's legal,
what's not legal and what people were tolerating.
It's just not the same as it was 10 years ago.
Catch them and selling as fast as you can.
I just get out while you can because there might come a point in time when not
only could they not sell it,
but they might be responsible for doing exactly what you said and bringing it
back to the area where it's family would be in,
which would be an incredible cost,
would be an incredible cost.
It would be an undertaking unlike any other rescue,
uh,
that we know of.
And uh,
how much would something like that cost?
I can't even imagine.
I mean,
I would be the wrong person to ask.
I can't put a figure on it.
I just know that it would take a lot of time.
Uh,
it'd be a lot of dedicated.
I mean we would need the pod.
Yeah.
You'd have to figure the vessels that would be able to bring the whales out.
I mean,
and you'd have to be able to somehow know that,
get it close enough to the other worlds without freaking them out.
It's a whole thing.
But it's possible.
I mean,
that's the important part.
Fuck man.
The whole,
it's just one of those things I really think as people we're going to look back
on and we're going to go,
man,
how did we in 2019 not know that that was insane.
Does that is not a chicken,
you know what I'm saying?
I mean,
that's not like something you could just keep in a cage.
That's that.
So let's back up to,
uh,
as you know,
at for well over four and a half years,
five years now,
I've been advocating for bill s two or three,
which is a ban against,
uh,
which is a national connect Canada wide band against a whale and Dolphin and
porpoise captivity.
So that would include no more breeding,
no more important,
no more export,
any of that.
Okay.
During these,
this,
by the way,
is going down as the longest bill ever researched in Canadian history because
it's been a lot of issues from a opposition.
Uh,
one,
one senator in particular,
in fact,
that if I can have a moment to just give a senator Don Plett a big goal.
I,
when you piece of Shit,
which camera do I look at to that I when you piece of Shit,
sorry,
I should,
I should be more humble.
But was that the other guy,
the lawyer of Nissan?
No,
no.
This is the senator that has put every possible,
um,
block in front of the passage of this bill.
He's tried to kill it silently forever.
I mean,
this is an epic,
epic story we've had to,
as activists and the community at large,
and again,
I have to stress how much you've had a hand in this is I've had to,
I've had to have these campaigns where we literally flood the Senate servers to
the point of crashing it on that on a couple of,
uh,
incident,
instances where they were going to kill the bill very silently through a sort of
procedures he's got as his role is a,
it's called the Senate whip.
So he's actually yields a lot of influence in power.
He,
he,
uh,
creates the committees where people do the studies and everything.
He sets the,
uh,
the dates for the committees.
I mean,
he had this thing studied for like 17 straight months.
It was absurd.
Again,
longest tenure in a,
in a Canadian legislative history,
it appears.
But this guy was,
you know,
doing his,
his,
uh,
so he used to kill it.
Do you think that,
what do you think,
like why was he doing that?
He's one of these guys who looks at this bill and he sees it as a activist,
sort of left wing,
um,
liberty,
you know,
liberal sort of fluff bill.
He doesn't see that it's necessary.
He went to marine land as an invited guest.
Uh,
he's very,
uh,
publicly declared his friendships for John Holder.
I don't want to speculate as to whether there's been any,
uh,
money exchanges,
but I know he's certainly very interested in killing this bill and by virtual
loan of activists pressuring and exposing all of his,
his efforts,
we actually saved this bill on a number of occasions,
the most notable of which was just a few weeks ago where,
uh,
in the House of Commons,
it appeared this bill was going to die.
And literally at the 11th hour I packed up,
we drove to Ottawa.
I had a tweet storm set up.
We put pressure on.
I tweeted,
individual senators are rather individual members of,
uh,
of parliament and,
I promise them,
and you know,
this is a sensitive time in Canadian politics for Justin Trudeau,
the of the PR of the Liberal Party.
I,
I them if this bill dies on account of the fact that what was happening was the
liberals were going to propose amendments to the bill last second that would
send it back to the Senate for further review.
At which point we know Don Plett was waiting in line to kill it.
There was nothing we could do at this point.
This was going to be his to kill the fact that this was being facilitated by
liberals was really infuriating thing.
But nonetheless,
we applied an incredible amount of pressure.
I drove my ass down there,
I got there and I stood in front of every,
which one of them,
and I looked them all in the eyes and just like,
I'm gonna make you famous.
I'm going to make you famous and I'm going to make you famous and,
and make you famous.
And,
uh,
I don't want to speculate if that's what,
if,
that's what saved the day,
although it was mentioned in the House of Commons,
that special interest pressured them at the last second,
but in a,
in a last illegal,
can you say that to someone?
I'm going to make you famous.
I think it's,
it's my most of my most effective tool.
It's like a scene from a like,
um,
what's that?
What are the,
what was the cowboy movie where Val Kilmer played a
doc holiday member?
Tombstone?
Yeah.
Sounds like a line in tombstone,
right?
Oh No.
You know what it's from,
uh,
the one with a Bon Jovi Song.
You know,
those,
you know,
shot down in a blaze of glory.
You know,
you know those,
those,
uh,
those cute guys in the it,
was it the eighties or nineties that are all like did a western movie together?
Yes.
It's from that.
And we'll make you famous.
Oh Shit.
Sorry.
I knew I had heard it from somewhere.
I think it's from that.
I'd hope.
I'd hope that was my line.
But nonetheless,
it's what member Emilio Estevez does.
This was arguably the campiness cheesiest of the cowboy movies,
right?
Is it the campaign just today?
I didn't see it.
I don't know if they're all handsome devils.
Um,
sorry.
So,
so I show up and show up.
Literally they,
the right before the meeting starts,
the entire committee stands up and leaves the room.
We're now,
we're,
we're there and we're prepared for this to die.
I'm there for a funeral.
Uh,
they come back in,
the conservative members of the committee proposed there amendments,
the liberals,
which outweigh the,
uh,
the Conservatives are,
you know,
they're all voting.
So they're just knocking these things down,
knocking them down,
and then suddenly it comes to the liberals time to propose,
uh,
their amendments.
First guy comes up and he says,
I'd like to withdraw my amendment noted on the record,
sits down.
Okay,
we'll go to number two.
I'd like to withdraw.
My amendment sits down.
Number three,
I'd like to withdraw.
My amendment were like,
Holy Shit,
I'm looking back.
You know,
I've got some,
we've got some people there that obviously have the same interests as me and you
know,
I don't even know exactly what's going on at this point.
I just know that,
uh,
their faces are indicative that this,
we might win this thing.
And the fourth,
uh,
remember parliament stands up,
he withdraws the amendment and we save this thing in the last second.
And I absolutely know it was a pressure campaign because like I said,
I was going to come on this podcast.
I'd already had this date written for some time and this was going to have
political implications that I don't know that the liberal party could have
sustained.
It's a really bad time.
I think this came from the top down,
whereas efforts to kill it came from the bottom up.
This came from the top down.
You're not killing that bill.
I think people are understanding what dolphin captivity really is,
what orchid captivity really is the thing.
They're understanding that now,
and I think it's just one of those things that exists because it's always
existed,
but if it didn't exist now,
there's no fucking way anybody would ever let you do it if there was no captive
dolphins and orchids,
if someone just went around and kidnapped him with what scientists know now
about their social structure and their community do,
they're so complex,
the way they teach,
they have fucking dialects,
right?
It's,
they have dialects.
Orchids have,
uh,
um,
they have,
they share languages in different regions and actually have a different accent
of sorts.
I mean,
it's,
uh,
it's really remarkable stuff yet,
right.
It would be a global outrage if today as day one someone said,
hey,
look at this thing.
Let's put this in this box.
I mean,
because we have a more ready,
well,
because we have them in,
there's some legacy businesses that have been around for a long time.
That's a great way of putting it.
Um,
you know,
they have the means to fight.
They know now that,
look,
this is not going so well.
If you can,
you can see it in all the advertising these days.
Uh,
uh,
seaworld almost rarely shows any orchids in their commercials,
although it seems that the industry is sort of switching to baby walruses.
In fact,
they're there.
They're the new ORCA is,
they're sort of the new brandable cute.
Um,
yeah,
it really is.
It's happening all over.
It's happening in Canada as well.
The Vancouver aquarium is running with it.
Um,
yeah.
And same as seaworld.
If you go to their,
their Twitter,
it's,
you know,
I can't say that present day.
It's,
it's like literally the case today.
But uh,
yeah,
a lot of baby walrus stuff.
It's where it's going.
It's just,
they know that they can run with that at least for the time being.
What's crazy and all this is here,
this bill is passing now we know it's going to pass.
It's a,
it should be,
it should get royal assent come second week of June,
uh,
shy of some,
some catastrophe.
This thing will become law.
Um,
that's why marine land is trying to get rid of these whales as quickly as they
can.
They got to get them out of here because at least now they can just,
well it sounds like to,
to uh,
export permits have been approved.
So there,
so to Beluga whales are going to Spain,
um,
you know,
but now granted that's being facilitated through the Vancouver Aquarium.
This becomes an ugly mess here because when it comes to zoos,
they're all part of these associations.
Okay.
And these are,
these are industry voices.
Anything that's if at anytime you're told,
well,
this is an Aes that a accredited facility,
you know,
most schools for instance,
or,
or general people would say,
oh,
well it's a credit,
it's a good place.
No,
no,
no.
What that means is these places facilitate,
uh,
animal transfers,
one not to other member facilities.
It's really just a club.
And this club protects,
uh,
the interests of these parks and keeps any type of oversight,
lack their lobby groups basically.
So what's happened is now through the Vancouver Aquarium Marineland,
so marine line is sending these whales to Spain,
but they're claiming them to be Vancouver Aquarium,
uh,
whales,
which is not true.
They were never on these animals inventory or rather this facility's inventory
lists.
There's never been any knowledge of any of this.
But what's happened is because of Vancouver aquarium is accredited and has an
affiliation with the A's headache.
So in Canada,
we call it [inaudible].
The Canadian Association of Zoos and aquariums and marine lands is in fact not,
uh,
they no longer have their accreditation.
They did,
they didn't have the best of relationships.
Shortly after all of our revelations,
um,
it's all just written now it's just the industry as a whole is breaking all of
its own rules to facilitate getting these Beluga whales.
Marineland has 51 of them.
Okay.
There's five born every year,
but they always have 51 and they don't,
they haven't shipped an Orca out in nearly a decade at this point.
Um,
I mean,
you do the math at what's going on.
Exactly.
So they're dying.
They're always have 51.
They don't ship them anywhere else.
I can attest that yes.
Uh,
when I was there and in my experience,
and you don't have to watch my words because I know Marine Lens lawyer Andrew
Burns is listening.
Hi Andrew.
I'll see you next week.
Um,
in my experience,
uh,
yeah,
you're for as many animals are born,
you're just about losing as many.
So you'll lose two old ones.
You'll lose three young ones.
Not all the ones that are boring.
It would be successful just about half are.
Um,
so,
so what's happening now is the industry wants that bloodline.
There's 51 captive orchids,
whereas you know,
there's a lot of controversy in importing animals from other places at the
states,
can't,
in fact,
they can't bring them in from Russia without a public concert period.
It might still be the case with Canada.
So actually the public might actually be consulted about the import of these
five belugas that um,
marine land is seeking permit for it to export.
So that's something that certainly has activist level.
I'll be,
I'll be helping to guide towards the proper resolution.
But yeah,
that's all happening.
It is a race right now to get rid of marine lens animals.
And uh,
I've had,
it is a wild time.
It's a wild time to be inside the doors at marine land is,
I can imagine in the fences.
Uh,
and it's,
it's a most wild time for me to be on the outside because I've never in the last
six and a half years of litigation and just have my advocacy and being sort of
an,
you know,
basically being engaged in war with marine land.
I've never seen them work harder to suppress me and to try to silence me than
they are now.
Uh,
as breaking news just today,
marine land had built this fence,
aptly named fills fence around the park.
And just today we found out they blacked it all out with tarps because come,
uh,
this Saturday,
May 18th and certainly I'm inviting everyone to come join me.
Uh,
I'll be joining as an,
as a guest,
a big demonstration outside the marine land and we're going to protest it,
uh,
as they're,
as they're anticipating,
because on account of my coming on this show,
they worked very hard to try to keep me from a coming be speaking of anything,
see,
certainly not promoting this event.
So I certainly hope that this event is a,
is a,
well,
it's,
how did they try to do that?
Well,
because we're in litigation,
what happens at in litigation is you come to a point where you start to
negotiate.
And so
there's things that they want from me.
There's things they really want from me.
They want my silence.
The problem is
they're never going to silence me.
It's not an option.
I've said it before,
I'll say it again.
They can offer me $1 million to shut up,
go away.
It's not going to happen.
I'm not going to delete my Twitter.
I'm not going to delete any of my tweets that have the word marine land in them
is this request,
these,
this is layers and layers and there've been layers of requests.
Basically they'd hoped that I wouldn't come here.
They'd hoped something could be worked out in our litigation.
We have a,
so now I've chased marine lines.
So back when marine lands owner was still alive,
I put forth a huge campaign to try to get him to be examined legally by my
lawyer.
Much like I've,
uh,
had to sort of submit myself to.
Um,
but as these lawsuits and litigation continues to reveal itself as just a
perfect method of abuse,
you know,
that they're just,
the only resolve these things appear to serve is to exhaust both parties and
have them come together with a resolution.
So after six and a half years,
a marine land seems intent on a resolution.
They don't want to go to examinations.
So while we were in.
So while I was there to be examined a couple of weeks ago,
my lawyer said,
take a walk.
And the two lawyers began their talks.
We put off the examination because we believe that there could be some good
faith that could be shown between parties.
MMM.
It became quite evident that it was not the case.
And when we were to resume our examinations,
which was to be last week,
marine land on account of the fact that I was coming on this show through an
absolute tirade and said,
we are not doing this.
Now,
bear in mind,
this is a court ordered examination date.
I've got a,
uh,
a trial,
a coordinator who is trying to nudge this thing forward because I mean,
that's something that's a,
that's a motion I had to win in the litigation itself,
is to try to get someone to look at this thing so that it can actually move
forward.
Like,
let's get someone to manage it.
So we're,
we're in case management.
So that case management judge has issued a very aggressive schedule.
It's in back in February.
We had a court date of which thank you very much.
I A handedly Marineland at to pick up,
uh,
just a little more than $12,000 of my legal bill,
which is really on this particular motion in this event.
Uh,
kind of a drop in the Pan,
but,
um,
nonetheless a,
uh,
a sound victory in court.
Um,
you know,
we have a case conference call next week.
Now I don't know where this stands because now Marineland has breached the
court's order.
So we went,
they didn't show up the examination.
I got,
uh,
a fourth a what's called a certificate of non attendance.
It means the person that was supposed to be examined that they didn't show up,
a marine lands owner,
John Holder,
who's now passed away,
uh,
didn't show up to two of his examinations knowing full well that I'd have to
pick up the 1700 bucks to cop to just to be there to get the certificate.
And he's just not going to show up.
No big deal.
That doesn't seem to be any punitive damage at their and they,
they uh,
I mean we're almost seven years into this thing and there's still like
brutalizing me.
Yeah.
But we're at a point where they're actually in a very uncomfortable position of
having to keep this thing.
If you don't want this litigation to be on the public record and transcripts and
evidence and everything,
you have to stop.
It seems to me the courts,
uh,
appear to facilitate resolutions of that sort.
They like settlements.
I was promised to trial on day one.
It's what kept me going.
They're lying about me.
They're lying about everything.
Everything they're saying
and they're trying to exhaust you financially.
Well of course they are.
I mean that's the premise.
You counter suing them as well.
I'm counter suing.
The premise of my counter suit is so that they couldn't merely drop my,
my,
the lawsuit against me over a period of time and then that just be it and that I
would,
I would then have to actually file a motion to get some costs back.
I'd be lucky to get 50% and everything in the early days.
My lawyer said,
let's sue him back.
And so we did.
I'm suing them for abuse of process.
They're,
they're using the court's time,
resources.
Uh,
they,
I mean even for that matter,
we can extend that to the police and other,
uh,
you know,
departments,
organizations,
uh,
they're exhausting.
Uh,
these things as in bad faith,
they're doing it because they just want to try to,
basically,
they want to take away my right to free expression,
which is a Canadian chartered,
right?
I mean,
I'm protecting my own history here.
this is insanity.
I can't even believe that after six and a half years,
I'm still here at risk of being silenced.
That the fact that,
I mean,
look,
full disclosure,
I'm out of money.
The last time I was on this show,
we raised,
I mean,
and again,
thank you so much.
60,
maybe almost 70,000.
That's an a year and a half.
That's gone.
I spent my last penny last month.
It was a very aggressive last three months.
Do you have a go fund?
Me?
I have a go fund me information.
Yes,
please.
What is it?
It's a,
if you go to save smooshy.com s a v e s m o,
s h,
i.com.
You can go there.
There's a small documentary.
It's a little dated now,
but not on account of the fact that legislation,
nothing's really moved forward in the lawsuit and the legislation only just
wrapping up.
It's still very,
so please
spend the 14 minutes to sort of uh,
appreciate the story more.
I guess you'll get a better,
a more context to it.
There's,
you know,
some,
some footage in there,
some back,
a backstage stuffs.
You know,
it,
it tells the tale quite well.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a good piece.
Yeah.
Folks,
if you're,
if you're hearing this,
please help it out.
If you can,
you know,
do I say it all the time?
It's the thing I hate to do most is ask for help.
I really understands me well.
Your intentions are pure,
you know,
you really are a person who is going about this because you feel like you are
uniquely qualified to talk about it.
You have the actual information,
you know what's wrong,
you know,
and you are part of the system.
You understand that better than anybody on the outside.
Can they have my walrus and they have your walrus still we think.
And so when,
and so when in the litigation,
my lawyer says,
well,
here's what marina lands prepared to offer.
I say to my lawyer,
but what about the Walrus?
And he says to me,
do we talked about this?
This is crazy.
You're not getting a walrus.
Yeah,
I said to marine land,
I don't want no money.
Not a penny.
I want the Walrus.
There's two left.
Uh,
three have died in the last,
it's really in mere months.
Uh,
secretly I find out.
What would you do with her?
I mean,
ideally what I would like is I just want to transfer it at this point to another
facility.
I would love to see a transfer to the Vancouver aquarium or there's a facility
in Quebec as well.
I just want to be up pos.
I just want to possibly be in her life if she needs me,
which I mean,
there's a reason she's in one of two still alive.
If I would comment,
listen,
would you move to Vancouver if suddenly Dan Bilzerian gets on the horn?
It's just filling out this,
uh,
well actually,
I,
well wait,
there's a backstory to that too.
I actually got some beef with him inadvertently,
but what we'll get back to that,
but you know,
if you were to suddenly say,
Hey,
I got this,
uh,
Arctic Beach Front home and uh,
do you,
I'll buy you a walrus.
Yeah.
Move.
Absolutely.
I mean,
she's got another 10 years of her life.
I do.
You know,
there's only one way I wore this to be with this Walrus,
play the music.
Is there a better answer this to the story?
I mean,
really,
it all sounds so crazy,
Joe.
But here's 66 and a half years ago I was like,
I want the Walrus.
Right?
Suddenly here I am negotiating for a Walrus.
Call me crazy.
But so are they willing to negotiate for the Walrus?
Is this actually in consideration?
Yes.
Yeah.
Not without layers and layers and layers of compromise and,
but bear in mind.
Okay.
Not in the capacity that I see it.
More of a,
yeah,
maybe.
Maybe we won't send her to China.
How's that?
Maybe we'll send her somewhere and not deter that facility from a you visiting.
Maybe we could do that for you.
That's what I mean.
It's,
it's really bad faith it.
The problem with the thing that I have a hard time dealing with is,
look,
we're going to litigation and you know in in litigation you have to exercise a
certain amount of decorum and it's not exactly my strong point.
It's just not,
I find decorum to be just a thick layer of bullshit.
I just do.
Yeah.
You want to hope that there's going to be some type of good faith negotiation.
I want that marine land negotiates with additional hostilities and threats.
It's not worked for them in six and a half years.
What makes you think it's going to work now?
So here I think we're going down a path of possibly good at a good faith
negotiations.
The owner,
the,
the villain of the story is gone.
He's out of the picture.
Uh,
the,
the new president who was the,
the widow.
The wife is a wonderful woman.
I mean,
listen,
if I honestly and truly believe,
if the lawyer himself wasn't the controlling mind of the business now,
uh,
he sort of facilitating this transfer of,
of,
of the business as it was to just being sold off,
pieced off and distribute the wealth to the,
to the remaining family members.
I think that we could,
I think the story ends on a good note.
I mean,
I have no hostility.
You know,
I have every reason in the world to despise the man who sued me and I don't,
I don't even think about them.
It was never about that they made every case in the world.
Every argument that this was personal between me and him and what that is,
cause you look in the camera and say fuck you to people.
It's personal between me and Don Plett.
You can bet your ass that's a different story.
But you don't know what I'm saying.
Did I make them famous?
Well,
even in a way maybe.
Um,
so where do you stand right now?
Well,
I don't know.
So next week we're having a case management,
uh,
the case manager's gonna talk and we're going to see what becomes of marine lens
once again,
skipped examination.
It's so hard to believe this is still going on to walk into my phone.
And from the time you first came on the podcast and now that this has been just
as scratch and claw everyday of my life,
I live with this looming cloud of a threat of like,
there's people out there that really want me,
I'm not talking physical threat.
Okay.
They did.
They played their games.
You know,
I called every one of their bluffs every,
at every corner of this thing.
But you know,
there's something about when you say they played their games or they sent goons
to my house.
Yeah,
there's video in fact that there's on that documentary,
you'll see these,
they send some tough guys.
I mean,
they were sending people at 6:00 AM harassing my girlfriend while she's taking
the garbage out.
I mean,
it really got pretty intense.
Um,
but we stood our ground.
I was like,
this is not going to go down like this.
It's like you're fucking with the wrong guy,
dude.
Like,
listen,
I come from a place called Welland,
Ontario.
I don't know that you're familiar with that.
I'm gonna assume not.
Probably few people are,
unless you're an avid hockey fan,
because we have produced some pretty amazing,
uh,
Nhl talent.
But,
um,
you know,
at this population of like 50,000,
I'm a Welander.
I don't know any other,
a Frenchman.
I mean,
it's probably another thing to stress,
but I don't know any other way to deal with things other than sort of fight it
out.
You know,
you don't cower and run.
You don't,
you know,
you stare the threat,
especially when you're on the right side of things.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna sit there and take shit.
I'm not gonna,
it's not gonna work for them to continuously try to threaten me because dude,
I'm invested
and I'm not talking money.
I'm in a,
it's like a hostage situation.
It's how it started.
My only interest is ending the hostage situation.
That,
that my only interest,
I shouldn't say that.
Of course now you know,
I have interest in,
in,
you know,
I've been advocating for for bills obviously advocating,
letting people know that they'll sort of taking the veil off the bullshit,
uh,
that the industry,
you feel like you're negotiating for a hostage in smooshy
there.
They're using her as that type of chip.
Yeah,
that's there bart.
That's their bargaining chip.
That's what they got.
And the keeping this constant pressure on you.
It's constant financial threats.
Uh,
constant like my lawyer in fact,
and this is where it gets kind of weird because listen,
I don't understand.
He's supposed to be representing me.
The answer is no to everything.
Fight,
fight,
fight.
I want to trial.
He instead is coming with,
listen,
this is not how litigation ends.
Feel like you don't seem to understand how this ends.
You don't have a grip of how litigation works.
And I'm just like,
I'm glad that I don't because my guest is I representative of what 90% of the
population that don't know.
And it's important that we find out.
I was promised the trial because they said I was this,
this,
this.
Well,
let's get through that fucking trial.
This is what I've been doing.
This doesn't end with negotiations.
I want the trial.
Yeah.
I don't understand.
Like why would you sue me unless you want the trial.
Oh,
because it's a bullshit lawsuit.
Well then I want the trial because I need to show that I need that on my record.
I want that.
I want the truth.
They fucked with the wrong guy.
I hate to say it.
I'm the owner of all the lawsuits they've launched.
They launched in,
in,
you know,
an excess of like 12 and threatened.
And,
and it's important to note I've been threatened and I'm constantly under threat
of additional litigation.
And the only one left and the only lawsuit that's I'm the only person who hasn't
had to compromise,
uh,
their free expression.
It's the dirty secret about the legal business,
right?
That this is a loophole.
This is something people can do to people to silence them,
just to drag them through hell for six years,
maybe 10.
Who knows how long this goes.
Right?
And this is a case manage,
I mean I had to fight in court at great expenditure to get this case management
and if you put this up to the general public and have them look at what the
actual facts are and had them look at what these people,
what their businesses,
what they're actually doing,
it's game over.
It's game over.
That's a real problem for them.
The real problem is it's an indefensible activity.
Having those animals in swimming pools for people's enjoyment like tea.
But to follow that up with trying to crush people,
crush my fiscal sovereignty.
I mean look,
no,
there's nothing good on their side for what they tried to do to you for what the
business is.
I like to operate in full sort of transparency because look,
I'm,
I guess I'm sort of sponsored by the public,
so I feel like a level of transparency and all this,
but you know,
I had a little bit of money.
I'd won a TV show called wipe out and I had 50 Canadian dollars tax free in the
bank,
which I sat on because I didn't know precisely what it is.
I was going to do with it and I felt like there was a potential of a rainy day
around the corner.
It took that in the first six months to six months to hire lawyers for
everybody.
Everyone that was getting sued,
I was cutting,
you know,
$5,000 retainers for there's a purpose for this money.
I only have it because I got on the show because of my relationship with the
Walrus.
So I'm in for a good chunk of change here.
Uh,
it's crazy.
The lengths of which and the ability corporations have to destroy individuals.
The fact that the court is there to facilitate it is precisely why I want to go
to trial.
I've been told the figures are,
and please don't quote me and I'd love the facts,
but I've been told that something in the area of like 90% of lawsuits get
settled without going to discovery.
I want to be,
I want to be the 10% or less.
I want it.
I want a resolution by the,
by the judge.
I can sleep at night if the judge says,
okay,
it ends with this Phil,
you get a $50,000 of your,
at this point in excess of 200,000 in legal bills and marine land,
you lost.
So you know,
you,
you got to eat the shame and walk away.
I would assume be more comfortable with that than if Maureen Lynn said,
here's $100,000.
Don't talk about the,
um,
I mean even let's say in the best case scenario,
they said,
here's a chunk of change.
So let's just use $100,000 and said,
just don't talk about the terms of the settlement.
But other than that,
you have no impeded speech.
You can just be free.
I would be more comfortable with the judge's decision then that hundred k
because then at least I know exactly what it is that I went through.
I had the world can find out what function these courts have and what their
version of justices.
I mean,
I'm just still,
I'm trying not to be jaded because obviously it's a heavy load to carry as in
your day to day.
It's,
uh,
you know,
I've been on the cusp of crazy.
Um,
I'm thankful for plant medicine for sort of keeping me grounded and keep me in a
with the proper perspective.
But plant medicine listen to you.
Hippie.
Yeah,
well
they do try to call me hippy a lot too.
That's interesting.
I mean,
I'm pretty little bit of a different version of hippie I suppose.
I don't mind war.
Well your,
um,
your God cares about these marine mammals.
The walrus is like my daughter due to sounds crazy distressed it,
but as soon as you consider that factor,
you're just like,
dude,
he's got,
they've got your daughter.
That's a mess.
Trying to put yourself in the perspective that if they had your dog,
your neighbor's got your dog and is,
uh,
is an unimpeded Lee,
by your definition abusing or neglecting their life.
And you're there to just watch silently.
I mean,
that's disgusting.
That's disgusting scenario.
This is the poison that I live with.
I,
I need,
I need a proper closure.
I'm relying on there being a level of justice so that one day I can live in this
world without being just that old
Jayda dude look,
last time I was here it was not nearly as fucking gray,
like starting to feel the effects of longterm litigation.
You don't have a podcast to you.
I want to do a podcast,
I'm urge to do a podcast was urgent.
You well people,
you know they just,
you know,
fill your wish should have a podcast,
do a podcast and I had to get a real simple thing for you to do.
I know I'm running lots of saying you're a great talker and thanks Joe.
I appreciate that.
Why don't you do it?
I am considering it.
Yeah,
I really get mad at me that I keep suggesting the people get podcasts but we
just don't have bro.
Stop doing the,
you know you said to me when we were in Toronto at dinner,
you said you should be a comedian.
I say that.
I've heard that before.
Convenient for sure.
That's funny cause I've heard you mentioned that on the show a number of times
too.
I've got two people.
Well there's so few of us on,
there's more podcasters and there are comedians force or like,
it's not even close.
There's like,
um,
I think there's more than 600,000 podcasts now in iTunes.
So yeah,
there's not 600,000 comics.
There's like,
that's a big pool to wade in,
you know,
but I mean,
I'm in,
if I did it,
it would be up for my own purposes.
You know,
I would be,
there's categories of course,
and for someone new,
I guess you'd probably be in his conservation to category or wildlife or
something like that,
you know,
you would,
you would launch pretty quickly and it would be fascinating for people to,
have you ever,
um,
heard like one of the really well produced a NPR podcasts like the dropout?
Was it,
did NPR do the dropout,
the one on Elizabeth Holmes and the Theranose controversy,
the blood scanning stuff.
Anyway,
it's an amazing multipart series that describes how these people made this phony
blood testing technology and sold it and made millions of dollars in,
was they were worth valued at billions.
And now they're literally virtually worth nothing.
So it was by ABC radio.
That's who did it.
Nightline.
That's what it was.
ABC News Nightline.
But something like that could,
if someone wanted to follow this and and document it from the beginning in a
podcast form,
this is something that really could be like six one hour episodes.
If you were talking about your history with training orchids,
what you thought it was when you first got into,
when we went into that and several of the other episodes.
But think about this.
You and I have talked now,
how many times have you been on now?
This is my fourth.
Okay,
so each time it's been like three hours.
So all those,
all those hours of discussion.
If someone you condense that into your story,
I think it would be super compelling.
And then you could also update people on the case.
You could update people on the state of Marine mammo captivity legislation and
because there are countries that are right now waking up and realizing this is
crazy,
like this is really almost like human slavery.
It's like finding aliens and just keeping them in a cage somewhere.
I mean,
the timing's right.
I don't don't that.
So
yeah,
I mean perfect.
Again,
with the looming litigation,
I do get a little bit sort of a tongue shy because this is just going to be,
I'll be sued again,
man.
It's kind of freaks me out.
I,
I really what?
You know,
it's the same premise of writing a book.
It's like great,
write a book,
but it's like I can't do anything with it because I'll be sued.
I'll be suiting seat.
It's a virtual guarantee.
Now the,
the,
the bright side is,
it seems to me like a marine land is not going to be around for terribly long,
a terribly long time.
Once their dissolved,
oh,
you bet your ass.
I got lots to talk about.
I mean,
I would love if I could speak of everything without having to sort of watch,
you know,
I really do have to keep from saying a lot of stuff.
I'm not on account of it being illegal,
but just on account of the fact that it will,
it'll virtually guaranteed me additional hostilities and you know,
leaving,
she was kind of,
I can completely understand.
I completely understand.
I do look forward to that day where I'm sort of free and unencumbered and just
can just be fucking me again,
you know?
Yeah.
Well,
if you're in that business right now,
you gotta be looking at the future going,
we've got to get out.
We've got to get out before they take us out.
That's precisely what's happening.
So the speculation is a marine lens lawyer is now the sole controlling mind and
that's precisely what his job is to transition this from.
We know that they've sold property,
they sold the golf course,
they sold the camp ground.
Uh,
we know now that they're there,
uh,
I'll say,
I'll use the word selling.
It might not be the right term because marine land claims there'll be no
financial,
uh,
exchanges.
But,
uh,
you know that,
that's yet to be seen.
Um,
yeah,
the writing's on the wall,
they're going to be gone.
I don't think the wife has any interest.
What I mean she's,
she's pushing 70 something.
It's probably doesn't want to be a part of this.
She's never really had a heavy hand in it.
I mean she had her,
she had,
she sort of took care of the cash business aspect of it.
She sort of,
she had her role in it,
but it wasn't like a management position making decisions on animals,
health,
importing,
exporting,
things like this.
Like it's just beyond her.
So what,
what we've been told is that a marine lens owner in his final days,
there's a wishlist.
This is what happens to the park.
This is what happens with this.
And you can bet your ass that there's something about a walrus and there's
something about me in there.
What it is,
at least that I know of right now is obviously hostilities till the end.
I think that what's happening is the lawyer is fulfilling,
uh,
John Holders wishes with me.
I think it's,
I think it's in the books that he can't just end this thing or I don't know.
It's a,
at the time,
I know the guy's dead.
Let it go folks.
A lawyer doesn't like me.
What can we in the same,
we're talking a lot of shit,
bro.
You know what?
He actually said camera.
I told him to go fuck himself or whatever you said that's going to be in court
document.
I didn't say that.
I said that to senator,
but he'll run with that.
That's okay.
Will it be in court documents?
Oh,
he's watching.
He's listening.
I mean,
uh,
I sort of have hope that he suits you joy to say that,
but I sort of have fuck up.
Sorry.
Do.
Yeah.
I don't wish that on my best of friends,
but man would,
that's
when the sun is not going to happen,
but fuck.
Do you know it's not gonna Happen?
No.
You just target shirt.
You just put it out there,
man.
It's,
he's not gonna Jude Juju.
We talked about this last time too.
I think that what they do in terms of that business for their own sake,
they should stop for everyone that's profiting off that.
You've got to find an exit strategy.
And I don't just mean marine land.
I mean anyone who understands my language,
that's,
that's hearing my words.
You should stop.
This is not the future.
This is,
you can't do that anymore.
This is going,
this is going to look horrible.
Just a few years from now where people who've seen blackfish,
people who do understand what those things are,
the more we find out about dolphins and orchids,
the more we understand them,
it's going to be more and more.
It's not like,
oh,
wait a minute.
We just did some tests we found there.
They're like crabs,
bro.
They're dumb as fuck.
Like you can just eat them and it's not going to happen.
Man.
Where more and more impressed with them,
the more we study them,
I am more than happy to negotiate with the marine land that rather than signing
any type of non-disparagement because I don't want my speech virtually locked in
a,
uh,
in a,
in a legal document.
Um,
I'm a forgiving person.
I don't need,
I'm only responding in kind to their hostilities.
They come at me with war.
I bring it back.
I don't want to,
I have to.
Yeah.
I take it right back up to where they bring it.
Then they do this,
then I got to do this.
Then they do this.
I'm like,
well,
he fucking thinking.
It's like if they would just die,
just dial it back.
I can be a happy smiley,
not chirping marine land guy.
I don't have to be,
I don't have to do that.
I've done what I've had to,
to be where I am.
The man who was,
who created this scenario is gone.
We don't need the hostilities anymore.
So what is the lawyers motives exactly.
I don't know,
but I can assure you now that they've blacked out the fence.
They,
they're doing everything they can to suppress,
uh,
our information.
They've bought up all the billboards in,
uh,
all the available billboards in Niagara Falls,
so that they've got marine Marineland signs.
Because,
you know,
we have put up like as activist activist have put up billboards,
uh,
one of which was like right at the entrance of marine land last year was a thing
of beauty.
So they've,
you know,
they bought all these things up.
They really don't want bad PR right now.
My guess is trying to get rid of the animals,
mitigate the PR losses because there's already a sound foundation of it,
of bad PR and sell the property,
get rid of it all.
And I think,
you know,
they're trying to fast track and accreditation so that they can facilitate
animal,
uh,
movements and whatnot.
My greatest weapon right now unfortunately is that I can assure them a great
deal of,
uh,
of financial risk I have and I certainly can and am right now.
They need to take that into
consideration when you consider the price of a Walrus and let's just use the
number of 100,000 which is a grossly inflated number for a Walrus.
And let's say Marineland were to say hypothetically,
well,
why would we give you $100,000 asset when it's going to cost us less than that
just to finish this litigation and owe you a 25 k at the end of some shit?
Why?
Why would we do that?
Doesn't make sense.
And I say to them,
it's because I'm going to make that Walrus cost you tens of millions.
Consider that,
lose the hostilities.
I'll make you guys heroes.
We can do that too.
The narrative,
this narrative doesn't have to continue.
The narrative of war can end with the debt owner.
It could have ended,
but,
well,
they're all invested in it.
And one of the things about lawsuits,
it's like people when they get it started,
there's a game going on.
You're trying to,
when you're trying to win,
trying to get the other side of the cave.
I mean,
this is a lot of what this is all.
And obviously you've taken this very personally,
this is all a part of,
you know,
can I explain something really messed up?
I now,
because we're coming to an end,
the,
the law that I've been advocating for is going to pass.
Um,
this lawsuit is going to end.
The animals will,
I mean,
we're gonna find out what's going to happen to them in,
in the,
in the near future.
We already know what's becoming of some,
um,
I don't know what it's going to be like to live without a lawsuit.
Once the prospect has gotten nice,
Bro,
you're going to be on the beach two feet up.
When the prospect came round of me not having one anymore.
That's not how I saw it.
It's weird.
I'm oddly connected,
strangely addicted and married to a fucking lawsuit.
I can't,
you'll be fast.
It,
listen,
we'll get you through
more of that plant medicine.
It's like,
I look at that bag right there and says insane.
I'm like,
yeah,
no,
that's about right.
That's be real stuff.
That's stuff we'll put you on the planet that's outside Pluto that we haven't
discovered yet and I see you've got the Tyson ranch box.
Oh yeah,
man.
I got to Tyson ranch box.
He hooked me up and then that big box is from what?
What is the company that gave us the big box?
I was speed we'd that helped,
but I think the extracts company Abx extracts or I'm not sure who,
honestly,
don't know.
We shouldn't help the shout out that company.
Different things in there.
I had,
I was elbowed most all these box speed.
We,
they're the best and they're,
they're fucking,
they brought me a war chest,
so get in there.
I'm actually going to be on the Tyson's podcast tomorrow.
Are you Rianne Stoke?
I supposed to do.
It's amazing.
I was kind of stoked and then it,
it,
it got postponed to Thursday and I'm really like,
in what world am I sitting down smoking a bunch of weed with Mike Tyson?
Well,
it's the one that was created on account to these crazy decisions that I've
made.
The fact alone that we've come together like this dude I'm talking with,
with Whitney,
who's,
you know,
she,
she says to you that I'm a hero now,
unless she's my fucking hero,
man.
Like I say it,
that crazy lady drove all the way to Texas with a fucking pig.
She tried to like help this pig out that she found.
She Fed the pig and then drove all the way to Texas with it.
I love her level of crazy.
I think it's just fuck a perfect,
it fits exactly what this needs.
Uh,
and again,
I'm blessed that you,
that you sort of,
uh,
turned around to,
to me and I know she was,
she was looking to have a conversation with you,
um,
with regards to some legislation and with the dolphins and will kept him and
whatnot.
And you sort of steered or my direction.
Yeah.
Let me touch on the Dan Bilzerian think so is he coming here on in May?
Is that right?
Is on the podcast.
Not that I know.
Someone had said to me,
Oh,
I hear Dan Bilzerian gonna be talking before though.
Yeah.
And it was that he has,
I thought they was coming out soon.
That kind of made me nervous cause so why a couple of weeks ago?
Whitney's like,
just,
just drilling,
uh,
Dan Bilzerian on Instagram for having this polar bear.
Right.
There's video of a polar bear to fucking party and he's feeding it and she's
just,
she's a polar bear in a party.
I don't know,
it's like a big,
it was a big brown bear.
Like grizzly was big grizzly bear,
partly.
Yeah.
On,
uh,
you know,
electric fence around and everything else.
So she's Waze.
Probably one of his crazy house.
Yeah.
Oh,
Jesus.
Dan Bilzerian.
What the fuck,
Bro?
All my God,
he had a fucking brown bear at his house.
Look at the size of that thing.
Oh my God,
I'm getting anxiety.
Did he ever see the fucking,
what was the yeah,
the best they do.
Yeah.
The one where the bear rip the guy's throat apart and that was one of the movie
too,
wasn't it?
No,
the bear was in a movie.
The bear was in a football movie.
What was that movie?
Let's go along with it was a basketball.
I think he has been in a few movies,
but with the Will Ferrell,
whether he's playing basketball,
you're like wrestled him in the middle of the basketball game.
Was that the bear?
Yeah,
I think so.
Well there was a bear that had been in movies and had done stunted movies and
this guy,
the video is awful because the guy is literally just standing there and the bear
just goes up to him and just decide to attack and rips his throat out like that
in a second.
It's exactly that video minus the,
this can happen at a fricking time only.
You got 45 girls in the back,
scantily clad basically could happen.
And what's really crazy is that that bear that killed that guy,
they went back to training them.
They're not going to kill an animal that has value.
It's the same as the Orca that killed all the trainers.
Like they're not going to kill them.
It's just not going to happen.
But they were trying to like figure out whether or not he was going to do it
again.
Like Jesus Christ,
what do you have soothsayer how are you going to figure out what a bear's going
to do?
It's going to be a bare ass hole that's going to do the hair stuff.
The people that are bringing that are trying to have you interact with these
animals like that,
they're,
they're relying on the animal's shock factor,
the shock and awe.
You know,
they're bringing these animals in the close proximity to scare you.
It's like that's a fucked up thing,
man.
That's the bear right there.
Look at that.
See that throat apart.
So horrific.
So back to the Whitney thing.
So Whitney's just,
just harping on Danville's ended,
he's deleting the comments as quick as she's tossing them.
So I decided,
okay,
well I'm going to weigh in now.
Right?
So I throw a comment and then I forget about,
I turned the light,
go off,
do my thing,
and then that night I'm on the field to Frankel show,
not me personally,
but he actually takes the comment because they know it's got a lot of likes and
stuff.
I said something to the effect of,
uh,
you know,
that's an abused animal,
blah,
this and that,
said something,
you know,
smoke more weed.
Anyways,
they,
the comment up,
oh,
by the way,
the guy who handles the animal,
he was sort of,
he was using some legal,
uh,
sort of jargon with me as if he'd maybe was talking about lawsuit.
And I said,
fuck it,
sue me.
Legal jargon.
We present to the defamatory.
Oh,
because I said,
that's a starved,
abused a animal.
I mean,
I know how to,
I know in the history of wild animals,
when is a bear ever walked out?
And today I'm going to become fuck friends with someone today.
You know,
fuck this shit.
I'm going to be card them out when they're a little cubs,
you know that of course.
So they starve them.
They abuse them.
They have the,
I mean,
but my definition of low ses,
but do they have to do that to train them?
I know there are people who claim to love bears that trained bears to take care
of bears and I guarantee you they don't all do that.
It says big.
No,
no,
there's nothing fun about abusing a drug.
Starved animal.
Delete this and you're pinched for animal exploitation.
Smoke more weed.
I don't smoke more weed.
Just like kind of help that.
But it wasn't a church though.
What do we uh,
filled the Franco said it was like,
I was like,
smoke more weed.
You fool.
I was just like,
no,
no.
Smoke more weed.
Like go inside one thing.
Okay,
got it.
Not True.
Yeah.
See,
I feel like there are people that have bears that raise them.
I'm not in any way,
shape or form endorsing keeping bears in captivity.
But what I see is people that have these sort of intimate relationships with
these really well fed bears,
they're big and happy and they feed them and get in the pool with them and it's,
it looks ridiculous,
but I don't think they're starving that bear and I don't think there abused in
that parent and I don't think you have to do that.
I don't think you can automatically assume that a bear is starved and abused.
So I assume the start part,
I certainly can't say,
but is there a big bear that was a fat bear?
Nice feeding it.
It might be hungry that day.
I mean that's born saying look at the body on the bear.
Oh big.
Not Well Fed bear.
You can have a well fed animal that's hungry for a week.
There's no question.
But it's not likely that that thing start.
And my definition of abuse is there's an electric fence around that fucking
thing,
which is there.
Yeah.
You can see about the ankle at about ankle was a fucking electric fence at Dad's
house.
Well,
I'm sure whoever comes back to that picture,
whatever installation,
the the person who brought this thing does has to keep the animal within
confines of [inaudible].
It was just went on a model killing rampage.
They kind of,
that's an electric fence.
That's again an assumption I'll say,
but again,
I don't see how that wouldn't be.
What the hell does that serve as a barrier?
It's just a trip line.
Otherwise for that.
So that's a welfare bear though,
son.
Look at that thing then mother fucker eats dead is a big ass.
If you want to get an animal to do something,
if you want it to be docile,
you have to train it.
You have to sort of,
there's,
there's breaking the animal in many cases,
but I'll assure you Joe,
that food deprivation is,
is in training is your most effective tool.
It just is.
You can find a healthy balance,
right?
But food deprivation is,
we've talked to one,
you've talked about this particularly with Dolphin.
To be fair,
in my,
in my experience of wild animals,
it is with a marine mammals,
so not worked with bears.
There bears that marine land.
It's a really,
it's a disgusting display.
It's an archaic,
it looks like it's out of the 18 hundreds even.
I mean,
it really is a disgusting place.
Uh,
but the practice was to starve them.
And what people do there is they pay like,
I think it's a buck and they get like this,
this little cup full of corn pops in youth.
The bears are like wave and yeah,
historically there's been bears,
I mean he's got,
they've got like 40 or 50 bears in this little confined space.
I mean there's nothing,
there's no more,
no greater abomination of nature then I can imagine than a solitary,
largely solitary animals are confined to a bunch of them of the speech.
And then historically they have ripped each other apart.
And Dude,
it's crazy.
I can actually delve into marine lands history deeper than I can.
Uh,
you get to hear the full spectrum of some of the things that happen in bear in
mind.
And it's important to note.
It was a different time,
different times,
different things happen.
And that's just,
that was the,
that was the norm.
It's,
it's starkly contrasting time to when marina and started.
So,
but the stories are like really,
um,
it's jawdropping it's really jaw dropping stuff,
but
it on one hand when you have children and you bring a child to the zoo,
on one hand it's really fascinating to watch this little person look at all
these different animals and freak out and,
and,
and see how amazing it is.
But that's the only pro is introducing human beings,
like little human beings in particular to these animals.
Everything else is a con except for the animals that are like really endangered
and they protect them and help breed them.
And then sometimes they were responsible for some reintroduction efforts.
But other than that,
it's an animal prison man.
Weird.
I don't take the position or Idl,
I don't,
I'm not at this person that's trying to represent an ideology necessarily.
I'm not against all zoos,
but I have to say that there's nothing more sad than seeing elephants.
Cats,
bears.
I mean,
cats,
man,
the cats,
when they're pacing back and forth,
I mean,
just get him out of there.
Who Sir,
whose purpose are you serving?
Is that good for you?
I mean,
seeing an animal that's got zoo,
this,
I mean,
it's a,
it's,
it's a mental case and we don't know what the fuck's going on in their head.
So we have no idea.
Most people just think this is just maybe normal or something.
Right.
A lot of people were not.
See because the veil is only now sort of coming off and people are started now
getting the truth,
uh,
on the matters.
You start to see things for what they are.
I watched the video on youtube some weeks ago and it was a marine land in the
70s and man was this place busy.
And the people were just,
I mean,
they were,
they were climbing over each other to be next to the pool.
I've never seen anything like,
I worked at 12 years.
I'd never seen the amount of people that this thing had.
And when you looked into pool,
there's a bowl Orca,
who's,
he spans the literal length of the pool that he's in on the side with his dorsal
fin over and he's literally staring at the wall and not moving.
And then you got two other massive orchids that are in this pool like fuck,
maybe five times the size of this room kind of thing.
And people are celebrating like it's,
and the view,
the video has like this sort of quirky music
and it's kind of funny and fun.
And I'm watching this going,
what a disconnect of time.
Like where this,
you're looking at exactly what you see today in terms of the animals,
in the conditions that they're in.
And yet here are these people having knowing nothing about it.
Just in the,
of the beauty of the met,
the majesty of these animals at the majestic nature,
these animals.
And yet we couldn't see for ourselves whatsoever how abusive and gross this was.
It was really a weird and strange thing,
but that's um,
marine lends a legacy business.
They built a,
they built themselves on a,
on having people come and experience the shock and awe of these animals.
And they did very,
very well.
Uh,
but that time is long gone now,
long gone.
I think we're going to come to a time in the future where people think the same
way about zoos.
I think it's uh,
we're just,
we're going to realize like,
I get that.
You want to see them?
I get it.
I get you want to see them.
I guess I lost.
I want to see them too,
but God damn,
we got to stop doing that.
Like this is no way also for the,
the problem is humans don't have any real experience with animals.
We have experience with dogs and cats,
which are these domesticated weird little fluffy friends.
They are not animals.
We don't have much experience with real animals.
And even the animals that you have experienced with their urbanized,
you know,
like pigeons that you can feed or squirrels that take peanuts from you.
He can't out into the world and the world of the wild of forests and mountains
and you,
you see actual real animals and it's almost psychedelic.
There's like a weird like paradigm shift that goes through when you see a wild
animal in the,
in the actual like,
oh,
this is where it's supposed to be.
It kind of feels weird because you're in their world.
You can be,
because now you're like,
oh,
what?
Because that,
the series of,
um,
of,
uh,
tools that that animal has in its world that doesn't translate in,
in captivity for instance,
is like,
wait a second,
that thing can spring on me to climb of Ma.
Like,
like I'm in its world now.
To me,
that's the awe of the experience of witnessing animals because since the year
and a half that expired,
that,
that from our last show,
you know,
I had the blessing,
the gift of seeing,
uh,
dolphins in the wild.
I went down to,
um,
I can't remember what Beto was,
but it was while I was in California and that was my first experience.
In fact,
again,
I'm from a small place and then this year I was able to go to Washington state
and see orcas in the wild.
Now I've jumped off Orkos rostrums into the air so high that you're looking down
into Dixie Cup to land.
I mean,
that's pretty awesome,
but there's nothing like having seen fucking bull Orca with an eight foot mass
on his back,
swimming next to his mother and all.
I've never,
my heart sunk into my stomach.
I'd never seen anything more majestic.
Wow.
Yeah.
Do you know anything about what's going on in the Pacific northwest where
there's a pot of orchids exists primarily
on Chinook salmon and they're starving.
So that's the,
so in fact it's important.
I'm glad you mentioned that because just a yesterday and today,
um,
a bunch of different protections are being announced for the southern resident
killer whales,
which are,
uh,
in the sailor's sea.
So it's going to impede sort of vessel,
uh,
you know,
they're,
they're really focusing on doing what they can.
What's happening there is they've got the Snake River dam system that needs to
be,
what happened is they put this system in and the Chinook are just dying.
They can't get through.
The flow has gone.
So they put the system in a long time,
a long time ago.
So it's virtually over time has been decimating these populations.
No one really knew why,
but we're at the point now that we know that these orchids exclusively each
Chinook and there's just not enough.
And whereas they used to be massive ones.
Now they've got these little tiny ones and you know,
there was,
uh,
the,
the plight of the southern resident killer whales is really,
I'm glad that it,
it's got getting global attention.
Um,
I'm sure you're familiar with the mother who lost his calf and mourned for an
excess of like 40 days and carried around on her head in the type of vigil.
I mean,
this was,
uh,
this captivated the world and you can't look at an animal capable of such
suffering,
uh,
without being acutely aware of the damage you're doing when you separate them
from their family,
the natural environment.
Let me explain the difference.
When bears see their cubs dead,
they eat them.
Yeah.
That's a difference.
This is the,
you're talking about something that's insanely emotional.
It's a different kind of animal.
And that's the thing that we're learning is the most notable aspect of these
animals is there.
So is there a emotional,
uh,
intelligence and capacity?
I'm afraid of what it is,
the depth of which we're going to find out that they're capable of a,
of bond.
Because particularly if there's ever some sort of a way of translating
communication,
if they figure out a way of breaking down those sounds and expressions into
something that we can decipher,
we right now they don't,
I don't think they know much.
I've been underwater with orcas and dolphins and I've heard them,
uh,
you know,
I've heard,
forget,
I can't even tell you the sounds,
I mean they've got a wide array of sounds,
but you know,
I could,
you know,
to,
to the best of my abilities.
I could tell you when an animal was excited based on their sounds,
they were making like one when our Orca Neosho was pushing me underwater to do a
rocket ride,
which is when you jump off into the air and you do this big majestic jump,
you knew it was going to be a good one.
When she let out this squawk at the bottom of the pool before pumping her tail
and lots,
you just knew it,
man.
This she was on,
she was on fire and then there's other times that you just,
you just knew she wasn't into it and I could just,
I could know by the sounds you can really determine underwater sound alone.
You could really get to know your animal.
Again,
I was there 12 years.
I mean,
I really get to experience a lot of things other people can never really truly
understand,
which is really why it's important.
Really important that I'm able to speak to these things because I mean even when
it comes to the legislation that is passing,
I mean I've had my name mentioned in the House of Commons.
I mean,
this is a national stage.
I had mentioned in the Senate,
I mean,
some people care about what is coming up just yet,
just a few days ago.
And uh,
a Niagara MP.
Um,
actually this would be a great video if you could,
if you could pull it up,
it'll be on my Twitter.
It's one of the things I retweeted with the MP,
the local MP.
He,
he bashes Marineland.
I mean,
that is a thing of absolute beauty.
I'm glad that I'm able to talk and explain to people what it is that my
experience has shown me and the things that I know.
Because if people know they'll do better
problem with the videos.
If we play,
that video gets claimed.
Oh really?
It's a House of Commons,
a video.
It's public and government thing.
Those usually are okay,
but I don't know if it's from,
is it from a new soul?
But you know what a,
the ad,
the group that put it up because they a,
okay,
sorry about that little guy.
If you go to my Twitter and you check it,
it's something to marvel is beautiful.
You have to be really careful with how I understand you've had a shit load of
problems.
Uh,
Niagara Region,
I can assure you this marine animal justice will have no problem with you doing
this.
I'm good friends with Kim allowed chuck.
We'll just tell people how to get to it,
but put that back up so I can read that.
Sorry.
Um,
it says,
um,
marine land and unfortunate in place with horrible conditions.
Okay.
Yeah.
He's a,
I mean this is a member of parliament.
This is a on the net on this is the,
this is the big stage right here.
And he's finally,
and it took a long time for people,
anyone in,
in,
in the,
in public policy to ever weighed into this subject.
And now we've got people outright saying like this place as a whole.
I mean,
wow.
What,
what,
how far we've come in the last six and a half years,
the world's changing my friend,
very changing whether people like it or not.
And this is one that I think it's,
it's unavoidable.
This discussion in this resolution,
this,
this has to be,
we have to come to grips with what that is.
It's just,
it's just all kinds of wrong man.
It's all kinds of wrong.
And,
um,
the fact that they're still suing you after all these fucking years as if they
think it's working as if it's serving them.
Any purpose.
Here I am again on the fucking jre.
Like,
are you kidding me dude?
You don't even know the favor you're doing me.
You don't even know what you've done.
Like,
come on.
What?
Like,
uh,
what,
what are you,
what do you want to accomplish?
What have you failed in accomplishing what you think you're going to accomplish
by kin?
Like continuing.
And Jamie is the virtual death definition of insanity.
It's not a good move.
Jamie,
who was it?
That was on the podcast?
So it was explaining the,
um,
the processes in place of reintroduction into the wild.
They were going to have stages in nets and stuff like that and these big outdoor
areas where they can transmit dolphins and orchids to who was that?
Do you remember?
Too many God damn conversation that me wasn't you.
We talked,
we spoke of the whale sanctuary project.
I mean that would be the,
I mean that's essentially the basis of it.
And the goal is that maybe it was you,
was it discussing how there's places where they're going to have like
intermediate steps?
Absolutely.
So much.
Amen.
Maybe,
maybe you guys,
uh,
expanded on it with someone else,
but know that is the basis of this project is,
and a,
I mean the good news is,
uh,
the whale sanctuary project.
I mean,
this thing is gonna happen.
It is the future.
They're there,
they're there.
They're well into the process of finding a site.
Considerations are being made for a Washington state's,
a site of Vancouver site,
but it appears as though they're settled on maybe Nova Scotia,
the community there at largest looking to work with them.
That's a wonderful,
that's wonderful news.
And I'll tell you something,
Joe.
Once this law gets royal,
ascension becomes law.
What happens is marine land is not able to export the animals unless the
minister of the Dfo,
the Department of fisheries and oceans concurs that it's in the animal's best
interest.
Well,
if such a site exists and marine land is keen on getting rid of their animals,
we'll have a place for them.
I told you last time I was here that my dream is to save whales.
This might happen.
Additionally,
if there's a real concerted effort of real effort to rescue those animals in
Russia,
I may very well be a part of that team.
So we're six and a half years ago I was talking about,
I was speaking of a crazy dream where there was no blueprint,
there was no foundation.
I just,
I'd sort of threw myself into the universe and said,
I'm just going to hang my hat on a dream I'm watching in real time as it's
materializing.
That's a hell of a perspective.
Humbling.
That is amazing.
This thing that we were talking about with the Pacific Northwest,
um,
there are,
it's the resident population that has an issue because they only knew each and
oak salmon.
But then there isn't there a another pod that comes through.
There's transients and they're thriving because they eat everything.
The transients are there.
They're giving birth to doing quite wealthy marine animals.
They eat marine animals.
It's correct.
The hills and stuff.
When I was there,
the guy that was with us literally said,
can you smell that?
I'm like,
no.
What is that smell?
That sort of oily,
weird.
She's like,
a seal is getting eaten somewhere.
Next thing we know,
we saw the activity,
you know,
the dorsals and everything and yeah,
sure as shit,
there's a part of a certain smile she could smell that uh,
that the seal was being used.
Why can't they teach these smart whales to fucking eat what their friends are
eating?
Why are they have to be rude?
It's like they won't eat Chinese food.
Fuck Chinese food or starving to death.
No,
I want a burger.
It's a rare occasion,
but there's something called a super pod where it's actually a congregation of
all the difference,
uh,
families of orchestra into this,
into this event where they all think they congregate and it's a big social
event.
And there's a conference that happens every two years in Washington state called
Super Pod,
which is organized by a good friend of mine,
Jeff Venture.
It's a,
it's an amazing event.
I look to being there again,
it's speaking,
I got to get to another place for me to speak and,
and Roma boat with experts and whatnot and learned a great deal of things.
But,
um,
I was,
we were on the cusp of that almost happening because the boats are radioing to
each other.
Like,
okay,
well we've got family going this,
we've got a family go,
this is like,
wait a sec,
there's three families going in the same,
same direction.
It's like there's gunna be a crossing of paths and this is where the boulders
get real excited about the prospect of a super POTUS sorts or conflict.
Or they have conflict.
They fight.
It could be,
but I mean,
for the most part it's verbal.
They just tell you like,
stay away from me.
Fuck you.
I imagine their messages are quite clear and you've got a 15,000 pound bull male
Orca giving you the bird.
Yeah.
You're going to listen.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Especially a trans.
He holds man.
Oh yeah.
When you see their mouths wide open and see their teeth,
you're like,
what the fuck are you,
why?
Why don't they start eating mammals?
And I wonder if anybody's ever studied the difference in the behavior between
the transient ponds at eat,
the marine mammals versus the behavior of the ones that only exist on salmon.
Like maybe they have a different,
maybe they're like,
you know,
like Avatar.
Like there was different,
different kinds of people up there.
Mike,
go to my go to source is Ingrid Visser.
She is a top,
she's the woman in New Zealand that swims with the rescues or cause,
I mean she is a top,
the uh,
the,
the really the global spectrum of wild orchids,
uh,
scientists.
She'd be the one to talk to you about that.
I mean,
you want to talk about a fascinating person to talk to.
Holy Shit.
The wealth of knowledge she has and she is a,
she's a very passionate advocate and I'm very proud.
I've done some very,
very good work with her.
So I'd love to talk to her to have her on the show.
I would love to talk to her.
I'm so curious about those things.
Oh,
I,
she would blow your mind.
No.
Well,
if there was a difference,
if it at all and behavior,
if you were to invite her on the podcast,
she would get on the next flight from New Zealand and come here.
I can assure you that.
So does everybody interested in the proposal?
I actually don't.
I like being home.
Fuck you.
Tell you what I think she,
I think she may have had done the total universe.
Maybe she told me that.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
they're amazing animals.
I always said that.
I mean this is coming from a self admitted big foot dork.
I'm a big foot dork.
I really wished bigfoot was a real thing.
But if big foot was real thing,
it wouldn't be nearly as cool as an orchid.
No.
Like if,
if we found some big stupid stinky aids has been hiding from people forever and
be like,
wow,
that's cool.
But is isn't much cooler than a chimp or a gorilla.
What?
Just cause it's bigger.
Now what an Orca is,
is really cool.
That is a super intelligent,
super killer that eats sharks,
death killing machine that they'll eat that,
that has great whites turn,
tucking tail and running.
Fuck up a great white shark like it has no business,
no business being in the ocean or the perfect weapon in their world.
I mean there's nothing that touches them.
They're literally at zero risk.
They have no predators.
I mean they're just too damn strong and too damn smart and coordinated.
They do their kills as teams.
I mean,
you're literally up against an army out there.
Try to be a 500 pound Celia and that would be a big seal army of 13,000 pound
killer whales who has a,
who sort of enjoy playing with you a little bit before you die.
I mean it's all interpreters play,
but more often than not it's training.
They lit the young ones and hunt and kill and stuff.
It can be a brutal thing.
I mean,
I don't love watching it personally because know I've worked with seals as well.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
I take team Orca all day.
Yeah,
me too.
You're not getting,
you're not getting great odds,
but put the hosts on it and you'll,
you'll get some returns.
Every time.
Amazing videos I ever saw was an Orca with a beach seal,
the seal.
He had bitten it and toss it through the air and the CEILIDH made its way to the
shore and it was actually on the land just with a little bit of water.
And the ORCA beached itself grabbed a hold of seal and just start smashing it in
the water there.
And you see the water just flood red with blood and then it hops back and
wiggles itself back in the water and swims away.
You're like,
holy fuck crazy.
Holy Fuck.
These things were beached themselves,
I think is 15,000 pounds.
So that is now.
Do they ever get stuck?
Yeah,
they do.
They do in New Zealand.
In fact,
that's where it,
Ingrid's work is,
uh,
is really special that she's,
dude,
this is a crazy story.
I have a friend that I grew up with,
uh,
Matt Harrison.
He went onto the to be,
I'm real involved in the army's,
they decades into the army now.
He was on a training mission in New Zealand.
They were doing this training on a beach and didn't they get called to go
perform an Orca rescues?
Just like,
oh,
what's now?
He's running and now they've got shovels.
They're trying to figure this thing out.
And now Ingrid shows up as the,
you know,
that's,
she's the person to call.
And now there's a photograph.
I'm waking up in the morning to a photograph of Ingrid at this end of an orchid.
And my friend Matt Harris from the same place as me,
a little town of welding at the other end of the Orca.
And I'm like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
And I got to reunite the two of them back in Niagara Falls in the summer because
Ingrid had come down again.
And I'm like,
it's,
these are blessings that I couldn't have even ever imagined.
And yet here he was.
And you know,
and he'd be the first to tell you when he came back,
it changed his world.
It changed them.
Never again.
Marineland done.
Whereas before it might've been,
you know,
it wasn't necessarily the case.
He was part of this rescue.
He's changed man.
Like he's just,
I mean,
now he's fascinated with work as like,
you can't imagine he,
he,
he got the bug now.
That's amazing.
Um,
listen,
is there anything else?
Probably a million things,
but no,
no,
we're done.
For sure.
I,
uh,
I'd like to give a couple of shout outs.
Let's see.
Just to give you a shout out to the Kanye West marine mammals.
What'd they call you?
The Kanye west of Lonnie west of animal trainer.
Oh,
there you go.
Absurd.
So a animal justice Canada.
I got to do a shout out to,
uh,
Camille,
who's a next level.
They're calling you the conduit.
[inaudible].
That's it from November.
Wow,
bro.
2013.
That started at all,
man.
I say,
wait,
they're calling you the con.
Wow.
The Connie was a Wall Street firm has to defend himself against one point $5
million lawsuit.
Wow.
Yeah.
Showed up,
man.
It's been an honor to be your friend.
Oh Dude.
You've,
you've,
you've changed the landscape of all of this by the way.
I know you don't look,
I get it.
I can do this all day.
The first shout out is to you,
the last ones to you,
the one in the middle's to every one of them.
Like you've changed my world personally,
but you've really changed the landscape of this entire thing.
Uh,
Whitney said at best today,
she goes,
you know,
Joe really is the guy to move the needle on this thing.
And I'm like,
you damn right.
So like a couple of fucks,
see worlds out there as often as you can and just,
you know,
keep this stuff up because you,
you,
you've had a heavy hand in all of this along with,
for instance,
senator,
Senator Wilfred,
Wilfred Moore,
who was the person who a tabled this piece of legislation,
Murray Sinclair,
uh,
I gotta extend a thanks to um,
um,
to the leader of the Green party,
Elizabeth May,
who's,
who's really taken this thing.
It's her baby and process this thing through.
And uh,
yeah,
if you didn't hear me,
shout out your name.
Sorry.
Okay.
Do it forever.
It's a,
there's some very satisfying things about having a podcast and one of the really
satisfying things is being able to let people know about something that for them
is very important.
Like there's many people that are listening to this,
as many people that are hearing this,
that are trying to understand with your busy life,
with your bills and your relationships and your work and you're,
you're also living in a world where something is happening that most likely
would be thought of as a horrendous act in just a decade or two decades,
and then we're going to be looking back saying,
how the fuck did we let this slide?
How did we do this?
And I think guys like you,
if it's not for your sacrifice,
many millions of people don't understand this as well and that's real.
That's you.
That's 100% you,
your sacrifice,
your ability to describe it so eloquently and your courage to keep fighting
this.
This is very important.
I haven't put it to the human race.
I've had faith through and through and it's right.
It's not failed me.
Listen to,
you're right,
you're right.
When it comes to this.
You're right.
When it comes to animal,
these marine animals that are super intelligent,
being stuck in swimming pools,
it's fucked up.
It's gotta stop.
It's gotta stop while we understand what it is.
You can't keep your head in the sand with this.
This is,
this is madness.
This is a terrible,
terrible thing and we need to stop it.
Well,
as much as I've had a hand in it.
Uh,
thank you,
Joe.
My pleasure.
Listen.
Thank you.
Um,
while we're Swissper on Twitter,
Instagram,
yeah,
I'm just learning to Instagram,
but I'm getting pretty good at all.
Walrus whisper.
Well,
there's the one on Instagram has got a,
it's got a little bit of a different,
but I'm telling,
you know,
it's,
it's attached to my Twitter there,
but if you look up filled dimmers,
you'll get,
you'll find it all.
It's easy enough to find.
You're a bad mother fucker,
Phil.
Thanks Fran.
Bye everybody.
See you.
[inaudible].